foreign
welcome to Africa
we are a continent that is rich in
diversity we have diverse resources in
Botswana you can find diamonds
in Dr Congo there's Cobalt and in Ghana
you find gold
and then there's the food
Africans have found countless ways to
prepare rice
from the jollof in the west to the Palau
in the East but for me
our Most Fascinating diversity is our
dance
I am passionate about African dance
because
I'm a dancer
and I'm African but I also believe that
dance is important and through it we can
learn so much about our history and
where we come from if the African
culture was a tree then I think dance
would be its flowers if you look at the
African dance of today you'll find that
its core Foundation is traditional dance
and these are dances that were created
with a specific purpose for a ceremony
or a celebration it could be for war for
coming of age or even to bring rain but
what's really interesting with
traditional dance is that through it you
can almost paint a visual map of
migration and so through the movement of
a dance you can trace the movements of
people and so even though Africa is the
most diverse continent in the world
we're also much more connected than we
think
let's take the Zulu Kingdom in the 1800s
the Zulus were Mighty Warriors ruled by
a Fierce and brutal King known as Shaka
Zulu a wave of Zulu people proceeded
outward into the eastern and central
region of Africa where they became known
by new names like the ingoni and the in
the valley of Zimbabwe three dancers
from these regions are known as indlamu
these dancers are essentially cousins
they come from their own families but
when you look at them you see the power
of shakazulu's kingdom
foreign
we find the Luba ethnic group
and they have a traditional dance called
mutawashi This Dance was used to
celebrate fertility and Visually it's a
liberation of a woman's waist
but a motwashi dancer someone performing
a traditional dance could cause a lot of
controversy to those who had adopted a
more conservative mindset from the West
in Zambia we find the member ethnic
group who are descendants of the Luba
people
and so they share similar dances
one of the member dances is called
infunkutu and it's normally seen at the
lady's pre-marriage ceremony
just like the Luba people this dance is
a celebration of a woman
[Music]
oh
we move into the eastern part of Africa
we find a Showcase of the shoulders
the escista from Ethiopia supposedly
imitates the shaking of a rattlesnake
and it closely resembles two other
dances from its neighboring countries
the Kuda in Eritrea and the kamaveka
from Kenya
these dances are performed to different
rhythms but their core movement Remains
the Same
[Music]
it wasn't only a migration that
separated ethnic groups
but also the artificial borders that
were drawn by some guys from overseas
in Ghana Togo Benin and Nigeria there
were once no border distinctions and no
movement restrictions
the Ewa people can be found in each of
these countries and they perform a dance
called the Togo acha
which is dance to the Togo acha drum
pattern
although these people were separated
their dance shows an endurance of their
cultural connections
[Music]
foreign
once said the Curious beauty of African
music is that it uplifts even as it
tells a sad Tale
and I find this to be just as true with
dance it's restored Our Hope in times of
struggle in South Africa during
apartheid gold miners were not allowed
to speak while they worked so they use
their boots to create rhythmic bits of
communication
a dance known as the gumbu dance and
then there is zuglu in the 90s in Cote
d'Ivoire University students facing
economic hardship Danced by raising
their arms into the air as if making a
plea
so we danced to celebrate what we have
overcome
and so we find that a dance is not just
a movement but that movement embodies
feeling and expression because it
carries history and stories
today our modern African dance is a
fusion of styles that have come from
different traditional dances
that continues to celebrate and
appreciate our cultural heritage
have a look
[Music]
together
thank you for sharing African dance with
me today